good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
wednesday hump day hope everyone's
having an amazing hump day
unfortunately today's hump day has been
slightly derailed by the rain theo is
not here to celebrate
hump day and my book announcement but he
was really supportive last night so i'm
okay
hump day has been cancelled temporarily
derailed
is what i'd like to say so upsetting but
on my way in it was raining and i knew
that meant that doo doo doo would not be
here today and i don't blame you i don't
blame him you know who i blame
i blame it on the weatherman yes
or god you know what i see crying i like
to blame the weather man because i feel
like
he's like a more worthy adversary you
know i hate when it rains but part of me
always feels like whenever it's raining
it's because like someone is having a
funeral and like they needed to yeah
like
have it be raining because like they
always say like god cries and when it's
a funeral it's like the
person's like soul and so i'm like um
you know what i'll accept the rain
because you're going through a tough
time that's always how i feel that's
such a beautiful way to think about it
thank you mcclaudia beautiful
can i just say that yesterday was such a
fabulous day like
i actually was like throughout the day
having like such highs and lows like
because it was just like i was staring
at my phone my screen time must be like
14 hours so you want to check
sure let us know it was so i'm honestly
scared
i got home and i sat in my bed and i
just stared at my phone and i did like a
q a
um okay so this morning i'm already at
an hour and 30 minutes
wow but let's go back to yesterday i
spent a lot of time on my phone
yesterday
yesterday also doing the social media
blitz for your launch 12 hours
geez louise that's but that's all sort
of hours that's my standard like that's
not crazy for me
i thought it was going to be more that
is so crazy no it's absolutely
disgusting but at least like i'm
you know making business moves i'm not
like playing fortnite
right that's true speaking of business
moves if you have another opportunity
yet yesterday we announced my book
it comes out january 26 2021 it's called
girl with no job
the crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster it is available
on amazon um on all the platforms if you
head over to my instagram account
girl with no job you'll be able to find
all the information you need there and i
just want to say yesterday was such a
fabulous day
because i didn't even know that like
amazon had charts and i didn't i thought
that if your book is like in pre-order
like you don't make it to the charts
until you
are released yeah until you have a book
and you send me
like um number like one in personal
development and i'm like what and then i
kept watching it
and i made it to number four on all
books like for a brief brief moment i
was above
barack obama and like people actually
respect him like that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah that's amazing it's a sign of the
times you know yeah i mean
it was an exciting day an exciting
launch i think that the launch was a
successful launch
strategy it was like your social media
skills like it's funny because like this
is what i do
and like you really killed it like
jackie was being so
uh liza from younger like cross
platform integration just like really
taking care of all the social media
and like the publishers were like wow
it's so easy like they literally were
like this is great like
it's because you had a social media
manager and like that campaign was a
success back in the day like that was my
job
social media managing and i'm glad to
know that i still have the chops
you went back to your roots uh this week
that's actually like
my skill set is like social media
marketing and so i'm glad i was able to
put it to use
you killed it just absolutely killed it
and i'm so grateful thank you
um also speaking of exciting things
going down if you're watching on youtube
today
we have a sign oh yes sorry it took so
long um
and you know to be up in our last studio
did we have a sign
no so it's been a while so now the
studio is officially
christened done done yeah cherry on top
because we have a sign and so you know
what show you're watching if you weren't
sure and it could be confusing because
there are a lot of people who look just
like us
yeah i mean there are a lot of people
who like try to do like this set and yes
but now you know like this is the one
you're the oj
um so yes not to keep talking about me
but i did want to say one more thing
feel free
um also a very exciting update is that
if you haven't watched my comedy special
yet it is now part of amazon prime so
you can watch it for free so i just
wanted to put that out there
because i know some people hadn't seen
it and we're waiting for it to become
free on a certain streaming platform
and amazon prime has it for you check it
out totally free content upper
yeah speaking of cu's i did finally
start the redheads book it is just like
so warm and fuzzy and beautiful
full of life like lessons quotes
highlight passages you're just gonna go
ham on and i just think if you're
looking for that warm and fuzzy feeling
and like feeling good about humanity and
i'm only 50
of the way through this is the book for
you that's like a lot of the way through
yeah but i don't know how it ends maybe
it ends and it's like oh you'll lose
your faith
from what i've heard that's not what
happens so not only was yesterday like a
big day for us but it was like a big day
in pop culture there was so much stuff
that happened
so much stuff like the fast five just
wrote themselves today and you're not
getting buddy valastro i'll tell you
that yeah no we're not circling the
drain on like biz news
um but um there was also the episode of
the bachelorette which i said i wasn't
gonna watch
but i did and i'm really glad that i did
that you did because i'm about to go in
on like well one person who claire oh of
course and you know what today i'm gonna
sit back relax and enjoy the show
i have no devil's advocate to play
do your thing see i feel like when it
come i'm hesitant to recap
how i really feel because i think claire
is getting a lot of hate and nobody
deserves that for the way they act on a
tv show she's not a bad person she's
just making poor choices
and i don't want to be a part of the
pylon i really don't because i feel like
maybe out of all the bachelorettes we've
had in a while she might be getting the
most amount of hate
oh [ __ ] you know what i didn't even look
after her comment section
is just are there are like headlines or
tweets or
it's people just people thinking that
they are important and that claire gives
a shred of a [ __ ] what they think about
her
um so while i have very strong feelings
about claire i will
be delicate because i i actually i do
feel bad for her and i don't condone
bullying in any way and i think that
she's getting like
really destroyed oh wow i haven't seen
anything but that is very considerate of
you and it's important to remember that
like while you may not agree with what
claire's doing like
she's just a girl on tv like she's not
murdering people she's just making
questionable dating decisions
which i know some of you people have
done before so just
remember that when recapping what's
going on
she didn't lie i didn't lie it's like
please let's look at your dating record
girlfriend okay oh wow okay you don't
have to be mean to them no sorry no i'm
totally kidding
um also like you didn't go on tv to talk
about your dating record therefore your
dating record is
your business inadmissible it's
inadmissible in this court yes
but yeah so we will talk about that in
our tv recap segment but it was a great
episode
lots of i think you know more
like serious conversations to be had
yeah and honestly the things that stuck
out for me
considering we know she leaves with dale
like watching how that happens like
isn't so crazy
but like that kiss situation awful awful
i can't i can't
i had to watch it twice like to try and
see what happened like like
playback slow-mo what's it called in
sports
replay yeah instant reboot it's not
called that in sports it's called that
in english well they use it in sports
yes i agree and part of me thinks that
she felt
it had nothing to do because he did not
pull away like when you replayed did he
pull away
no i mean she did go in like 95. she
went very aggressive but like okay it's
okay for you what we're not living in
the 19th century like
you can kiss someone but i think that
she like went in for the kiss because
she like thought it was like what she
was supposed to do and then she felt
like she was cheating on dale
and pulled out like that's literally how
i felt she's like oh wait no i have a
boyfriend oh
[ __ ] that's how i felt yeah we need to
we need to dissect it because i was i
was left
so confused so confused but um we'll
talk about that in the tv recap
maybe we should just get in because we
have unless there's any more personal
matters that you'd like to discuss i
didn't watch any more queen's gambit
yesterday
because my eyes were just glued to my
phone refreshing my instagram comments
telling
oh i'm sorry i have to say one thing but
you talk queen's gambit like it's my
sweet treat
waiting for me but i have to finish the
redheads book because we're recording
the redheads episode on thursday which
is a reminder if you want to ask us any
questions about the book
email us the redheadsbookclub gmail.com
so i have to finish this and then do the
outline before thursday if i finish the
book like today i can watch queen's
gambit tonight
yeah no i didn't watch any yesterday and
i'm really enjoying it it's a limited
series so i don't think i have that many
episodes so savor it
i'm going to but i wanted to address the
controversy um
you know it wouldn't be a day here at
the morning chest if i didn't address
some of the haters
and i want to address
maxie padgate oh wow is it has it gotten
that big it's gotten pretty big it's
gotten beyond what i thought
when i announced my book of course
everyone was so excited but many people
were quick to point out that my bathtub
on the cover does look a little bit like
a maxi pad and at first they were like
oh i thought you were sitting on a maxi
pad now i see it's a bathtub obviously
and i just want to say to the haters i
see you i do
it does look like a maxi pad and i'm not
really mad about it i think it's kind of
funny
and very on brand but no that was not
intentional i know a lot of people like
actually thought it was
i i see how the shape of the tub is the
shape of a maxi pad
but like why would you be laying on a
maxi pad naked with bubbles on me
like no it makes no sense but um i just
want to address that because you know
i'm all about addressing my
controversies
wow okay thank you for your bravery and
your honesty and speaking of addressing
my controversies i address quite a few
of them in my new book
girl with no job the crazy beautiful
life of an instagram thirst monster
now available at most retailers well now
available for pre-order at most
retailers sorry i'm getting new i'm new
to this whole to the jargon to this
whole authorship thing
yeah it could take some getting used to
i know from what i hear from what i hear
so now i think with all the personal
promotion behind us
we'll see about that yeah i know there's
a lot to talk about speaking of my
announcement my fun announcement is
tomorrow
so get excited i thought it was today no
no no i'm announcing
the show tomorrow okay guys jackie's
going through something in her life
that's so unbelievably exciting like you
have no idea
and i don't want to overhype it and
she's not pregnant
no i already told you guys that and like
let's just leave it at that yeah
um now after teasing
everything else it is time now it is
time for the fast life stories that you
yeah you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and that's true it's true but um
i'm not i'm not even gonna make a joke
right now i'm going through something
like really serious medically
no yeah and it's mask breath and it's so
[ __ ] awful
and i think everyone is going through
and i literally was out to dinner last
night and i gave everyone
the table a piece by the way we
literally have it here today sponsors
thera breath
they make a ton of products and they're
all geared for your breath like it's so
fabulous
but this gum is truly a game changer and
everyone i was out to dinner last night
was talking about mask breath and i was
handing out this gum like you need their
breath i'm like
a traveling salesman um it's the world's
fastest growing oral health care
solution for one simple reason
their products are powered and tested by
science they're not
gimmicky marketing and they have
powerful masking flavors far too many
oral health companies are driven by
marketing but at their breath
they're driven by science they are
founded by a dentist they are still run
by a dentist and each and every one of
their products are dentist formulated
to be safe and effective so they have
mouthwash they have mints
they have gum zach has been using the
mints like since before since i knew him
it's crazy powerful stuff and i am like
not only am i so sensitive to other
people's breath
i happen like i don't know if it's like
i have decaying teeth in my mouth or
something but like
i have some of the worst breath of all
time and like it's
really disgusting and i'm so conscious
of it and i'm always carrying around
like gum that like loses its flavor in a
minute but the fact that there's
literally a brand
that's dedicated to like taking care of
my breath like you don't know how this
helps me sleep at night and i love the
gum but they have tons of products no i
usually our breath is at its worst like
right after the show and i popped in a
piece of gum the other day and i
literally was chewing it for
four hours until i got home i like
didn't even realize it hadn't run out of
right out of pow pow pow so thera breath
fresh breath oral rinse which i now have
in my house too um is a premium dentist
formulated oral rinse that is ada
approved and clinically proven to fight
bad breath by attacking it at the source
which is the bacteria that causes it the
founder is the dentist dr harold katz
and he invented the first thera breath
fresh breath formula 25 years ago um
it's totally safe the oral rinse is
alcohol free for
no burn and it's kosher vegan
and gluten free so all of our holofrench
toasters you can get it on the fun
they contain no artificial flavors or
colors and it is never tested on animals
and of course made in the usa
thera breath fresh oral rinse comes in
three delicious flavors um i like the
gentle mild mint the best and so does
ben but tons of flavors fabulous
fabulous delicious flavors
be sure to check out therabreath if you
have mask breath or just bad breath in
general
therabreath is therabreath.com
t-h-e-r-a-b-r-e-a-t-h
dot com slash toast and if you want to
save 25 off on your order from the
website
use code a toast a-t-o-s-t at
thera-breath.com
toast promo code a-t-o-a-s-t a toast
to save 25 on your order thera-breath
it's like therapy
for your breath love it sign on
fight that bad breath y'all first story
happy news gwen stefani and blake
shelton are engaged
thanks for saving my 2020 and the rest
of my life
the couple made their engagement and
instagram official on tuesday with a
sweet post from gwen sharing a photo of
her ring
alongside her new fiance multiple
sources confirmed to people that the two
recently got engaged in oklahoma
she wrote at blake shelton yes please
okay
so am i the only one who like literally
thought they were married already okay
i thought they were 100 engaged i
thought they got engaged like
four weeks after they got together and
just been engaged ever since i swear i
saw
like a star magazine or us weekly cover
the other day
that said the wedding is off blake and
gwen
implying that they were already engaged
right and when i saw that i realized
that they weren't already married like
that's how far along i thought that we
were
i guess they just like moved so fast
from the second that they met like it
really was love at first sight
so it just gives off that vibe that
they're moving really fast but i guess
they weren't engaged yet which is just
it's this is news to me right like this
is shocking that like they weren't
already engaged and at this point
they're even bothering to get engaged or
get married
yeah no but honestly as a couple i love
them so much i actually really really
believe in their love i think
they're two people you would have never
paired together but once they met it
totally made sense and now they work
together and i feel like they just
really really love each other i mean
not to you know bring her into this but
like miranda lambert must be vomiting
just because like
they miranda lambert and blake shelton
got divorced and like the next woman
that blake shelton met was like the
absolute love of his life which doesn't
happen for anyone like it's so rare
and it's just like like if that's your
ex like
kill me yeah they're really perfect
together and
just go to show opposites attract yeah
it goes to show opposites attract and
goes to show you can find love anywhere
you know even at work
even at work is that where they met the
voice voices yeah she became
no no they met uh there and now they
work together there that's so
cute like i mean other if it wasn't on
the voice like how would blake
blake shelton and gwen stefani ever have
met in a room that was small enough for
them to even like
see each other maybe at an award show
right but those are so big like you're
not going to talk to someone who's like
not in your genre who you probably like
have never heard their music before
so i just we have the voice to thank you
and
part of why i love this couple is that i
think gwen stefani is very talented
i haven't really kept up with any of her
music since no doubt
and i think that blake shelton is also
you know challenging her musically
and they're making country music
together and like she's really becoming
an artist who
whose work i can admire yeah not that
she wasn't that before i just didn't
really keep up with her no and i don't
think she was putting out like that
much music right before they started
dating so this is like this next chapter
for her and i think
that it's beautiful and i just i'm
really shocked that they weren't already
engaged yeah i also think like
business-wise like this relationship has
been so good for both of their careers
because one everyone's obsessed with
them and like just ships them so hard
blake really became so mainstream like
with the voice and then with gwen
stefani and gwen stefani although i love
her like was kind of irrelevant before
the voice and before her relationship
and now she's like a-list
so i just think like from all angles
from all cylinders like this
is perfect yeah no and i i s it's clear
that they feel similarly
yeah no i'm i'm actually like really
happy for them yeah i wonder if they
will
get married though i don't know i don't
know either
who has more money blake shelton oh yeah
he's like such a big star
yeah like top hit two hits hits
for like 20 years yeah no he kills it
yeah and he really
like did good work for country music in
the mainstream like pop sector
with his work on the voice people just
love him even though they've never heard
of him he's very personable he's very
funny
he's like one of my favorite people to
watch entertainment wise on
the boys i haven't watched a voice in
forever me neither but i follow them on
tick tock so it's basically like i watch
because they upload
so many clips that's great you know it's
it's an amazing way
to be a fan of the voice i feel like i
actually believe that that
is true you know like literally all the
blended auditions are on their tic-tac
page and they're clipped like the best
part
of the audition like where people turn
around and then they tell you whose team
they're on like it's literally all you
need to know
interesting yeah it's a good follow i
highly recommend it if you spend as much
time on tick tock as i do check out nbc
the voice not an app
if you want to reach 12 hours of screen
time a day yeah
check out nbc the voice and if you're
spending that much time on your phone
maybe follow me on tick tock and then
pre-order my book lincoln bio
interesting thought i promise i will
stop with like the book stuff i just
can't get over it
okay next story our queen kim
celebrated her 40th birthday on a
private island
with a trip for all of her closest
friends and family except kylie
okay and i want to say something i have
a prediction and i i want to put it out
in the ether before you can say anything
i think kylie's pregnant you do i do
i'll have to look into this she's
spending more time with travis
she was not on the trip or if she was
she wasn't photographed
she wasn't on the trip she was in
houston with stormy and travis
yeah so i think she's pregnant and i'm
putting it out there and i
like i really think i'm right okay i'm
gonna look into it like
with my investigative and i just want to
say like i have absolutely no
proof it's just a feeling you know it's
that maternal instinct
yeah i mean it has it strange that she
wasn't on the trip one like to celebrate
her sister too it looked like the most
iconic trip
of all time can you imagine like in this
current climate like
having the opportunity to go on a trip
like that and not going
no i can't relate no cannot relate uh
they were in a tropical location for the
luxurious getaway
we saw some behind the scenes footage of
kkw air
a plane that kim chartered it looked
like the biggest
type of plane you could get like a 747.
it was a 777
and literally i saw like videos from
inside the plane and i thought it was
like a set i didn't think it was a real
plane that was taken off and then
look out the window and they're in the
air it looked like soul plane like the
movie like it looked like a set
yeah no it's crazy like it was jumping
yeah
and kim has been sharing photos from
the weekend or i guess this was in the
past people obviously like didn't share
stuff while they were there
i think they're all home by now very
well kept secret very well kept secret
she explained all of the different um
ways in which they
took precautions she captioned um
carousel photos on instagram saying for
my birthday this year
i couldn't think of a better way to
spend it with than with some of the
people who have helped shape me into the
woman i am today
before kovit i don't think any of us
truly appreciated what a simple luxury
it was to be able to travel
and be together with family and friends
in a safe environment
i surprised my closest inner circle with
a trip to a private island where we
could pretend things were normal
for just a brief minute she said i
realized that for she explained they
dance road bikes swam near whales kayak
watching
beyond the beach but she said i realized
that for most people that this is
something so far out of reach right now
so in moments like these i'm humbly
reminded
of how privileged my life is that's nice
i guess i saw this caption these photos
and i was just like
this is so beautiful like nice for her
nice for her
i could do it oh i'd be there in a
second but the backlash
y'all is people are like so upset about
it
it's very tone deaf i want to read some
of the headlines i just searched kim
kardashian
i went to the news category the cut
billionaire humbly checks her privilege
on private island
uh wait there's vanity fair kim
kardashian west could have
could always have fun and not post about
it washington post kim kardashian
dragged for boasting about lavish island
birthday party
quote read the room daily beast kim
kardashian's tone deaf private island
40th birthday bash post draws backlash
full of perfect memes like so nasty
you know people are really mad given the
current climate what's going on in the
world people have lost their jobs
they think that kim sharing this part of
her life
could have been kept i don't know if
they're mad that she did it i think
they're mad that she posted it oh [ __ ]
off no i mean that's literally her job
that's literally her job like i saw
these pictures
and they brought me like some joy i was
like wow this is so
stunning like the looks everyone looks
so happy like this is what we've come to
like know and expect from the
kardashians
like i let them live
no and you know at some point like as a
society we really
just need to like lay off of people and
realize like it ain't that deep like if
if if literally anyone in the world
was a billionaire and had the
opportunity to do that like they would
do it too and they would share posts on
instagram
and i just think like we got to let
people live and just like we got to let
people live
if you don't like it just unfollow you
don't write an article about it don't
have to write an article like it doesn't
have to be a whole think piece like if
you don't like it
don't follow some of us do like it so we
do follow no i want to see more pictures
i want to see more pictures like and she
was clearly very
she there she very much like understands
that this is not the norm for people
of course very like careful about what
picture she posted
the statement that she crafted to
celebrate like what was going on in her
life and also acknowledge that
this is not what everyone can do this is
not so that's not something i can do but
i
appreciate being able to watch her do it
yeah and i don't know if i just like
am defending her because i love her and
like if it was someone else like would i
feel the same i don't know
but at the end of the day like i'm
unbothered and i just love her and i
just think
like we could really learn to operate in
a world where like we just get out of
people's business like
it not everything everyone's gonna do
you're going to agree with and that's
part of just being an adult and
living in the real world and you don't
have to like throw a tantrum and talk
about every time someone does something
that you don't agree with
and that's the hill that i will die on
here today i agree and i can't imagine
that if even if it wasn't kim that i
would feel differently
about people living their lives and and
now it's like you
like before it's like oh how how
reckless and irresponsible is you're
doing a party with your friends but like
no
that part's taken care of like they all
got tested quarantined
etc they were clearly very safe so now
it's like how dare you do this when
other people can't
well then if everyone only did things
other people could do
like it's just it's so silly it's so
silly um
also kim like does so much good work
she's so charitable she donates so much
of her
time so much of her money i agree with
her platform her platform to helping
other people
like it's her 40th birthday it was his
40th birthday
no that's true it's like we like like
social media is just so ruthless like
you can never be doing enough like
and if you take one moment for yourself
people are like you're selfish
even though like homegirl literally just
donated a million dollars like she's
always posting about important things on
her instagram she literally devoted so
much of her life to
criminal justice reform like can she's
generally becoming a lawyer in order to
help people can we literally
just like let a [ __ ] breathe it's just
it's ex
housting i mean and i'm not even one of
those people like but it must be
exhausting
to constantly be searching for things to
be offended by like it must be
exhausting
yeah it really really must be i was
shocked when i saw like that there was
so much hate for this
like i could barely find a story that
didn't have like a slant about her tone
deafness
and don't get me wrong like i totally am
sympathetic and i understand like we are
living in
unprecedented times and it's like it's
absolutely horrible like people losing
their jobs
businesses literally in on my block like
every business is closed down it's
absolutely awful and i get that
but one does not you know going on a
trip doesn't mean you don't care about
what's it's just
it's a little silly that's all i'll say
it's it's a little much
like we all know the circumstances that
we're living in we've been living
with them for eight months like it's not
good out here
no but if someone can find some joy in a
way to do something in a way for
themselves
for themselves in a way that is
safe do it um but can we talk about who
was there because
tristan was there with chloe and so i'm
i think we're pretty much confirmed
they're back together
yeah devin booker was people were like
literally on tick tock were like
zooming into the background of photos
and saw him in two pictures so
he was rumored during quarantine to be
dating kendall jenner i believe that
means that they're still together
courtney and scott were both there i
believe alone but like alone together
we should be alone together um
so just like an interesting thing for
people to think about yeah very very
interesting i need to go through all the
photos this e-news article has every
single photo that's been posted so far
which is just like exactly what i need
and i feel like there's so many more
photos but like now that kim's getting
roasted like
she's not going to share them with us
and i and i want to see more like what
did you eat for dinner she posted a
photo that i saw this morning that was
like her
chloe and courtney on the beach like in
their bathing suits like looking like
the [ __ ] snatchers like
oh my gosh why didn't that happen to me
in quarantine no and it's like why am i
not friends with kim kardashian and like
why
why wasn't i one of those people you
know 20 years ago when i was six years
old
who met her and helped her shape into
the woman she is today how come you
weren't one of those people 20 years ago
when you were six years old like who was
in high school with her
no it's not fair it's just not fair like
that i wasn't on that trip like
and i wonder am i just so delusional or
like do other people see that and be
like oh my god like i should be there
because i really feel territorial like i
should have been there
i think i mean i didn't see that and
think that i did not well i did
so maybe some did some didn't okay
moving on to our next story a little
happy news for sheena shay oh my god i'm
so happy about this
she has revealed she is pregnant again
after a june miscarriage she is so
excited to be a mom
the vanderpump world star revealed in
this week's issue of people that she and
boyfriend brock honey davies
are expecting their first child together
after previously sharing in june that
she had suffered a miscarriage
we got pregnant so quickly she says my
doctor told me to wait one period in
ovulation cycle
and then we could try again it was the
first and only time we tried and i had a
feeling right away but it was so soon to
tell because i wasn't even close to
missing my period yet
i just had a feeling okay um first of
all
i'm so happy for her like she went
through something really difficult in
june and now to get like a positive
result
is just absolutely wonderful i have a
special place in my heart for sheena
marie shea i really do because
i think that she's been disrespected in
a lot of ways
on vanderpump rules and i think that
she's kind of like a hero of the show i
said it i did
and i just love that she's been through
so many toxic relationships like
michael jay is that his name mike shane
michael che i'm thinking i'm confusing
but his name is
parks valletta like of course madison
vlada there's just been so much and
honestly i don't know anything about the
guy that she's with but he looks like
such a cutie and like a nice guy and i
feel like it's a really healthy
relationship and i'm like
so [ __ ] happy for sheena shea i love
her we stan
yeah and in true sheena fashion her
pregnancy announcement was sponsored
by clear blue and i just want to say
like that is the benchmark of
you know as an influencer you've truly
made it like malika did one like if
you're announcing your pregnancy without
a sponsorship like what is you doing
i'm not about that like i will do
anything for money no i totally agree
like clear blue's legit like and she
it's like a nice organic post like she
integrated the brand really well really
perfectly like you know i was a social
media marketer on the campaign like i
would definitely be pleased with the roi
no and clear blue is a fabulous product
aren't they the ones you know you know
five days sooner
i she did five days before you're missed
period that's what it is
beautiful beautiful yeah no really happy
for her i agree her man does look really
cute and sweet and
exactly what she needs even though we've
like never met him or heard from him um
but maybe it's better that way because
maybe like a lot of times when like the
partner goes on the show
it's like yikes yikes bikes
what's it from yikes bikes i have no
idea i know
never been kissed when she's eating the
pie you know it's a weird word
fork she's like gets drunk at that like
reggae club yeah yeah
such a good movie good times anyways
happy first year and technically she's a
part of the vanderbump crew now
well yeah that's the other thing but see
the words of jordan pruitt from the
outside looking in
yeah because like the other girls who
are pregnant which is now lala stasi
and brittany brittany um i believe that
was intentional like to all get pregnant
at the same time
i don't know and i don't think sheena
was a part of that but china's been
talking about like freezing her eggs and
she filmed a lot of that for vanderpump
rules and she was very vocal about how
upset she was that they caught all that
footage out
so she's been on this journey for a
while i don't think she's a part of the
pact but it just so happens that it's
all the same time and i feel like it's
great it'll bring them all really close
together i want
i want china like to thrive in this
group and she just can't
yeah i think it will bring them close
together because last we heard from
the closest to her at the time was la la
like not do they were not on good terms
but maybe this will be the thing that
brings them together
bring sheena into the fold i would love
that for her as well
babies have a beautiful way of just
bringing people together yeah they do
okay are you ready for our next story
some beverly hills casting news
hearts kathy hilton will appear on real
housewives of beverly hills season
11. tmz reported the news on tuesday the
news comes one day after people reported
that crystal kung minkoff will be
joining beverly hills next season
um bravo tv.com says
kathy hilton will appear as a friend of
the cast that's what tmz said as well
i'm okay with that i think it's a really
good jumping off point
um i think maybe it was her way of like
dipping her toe in
i'm sure she has her preconceived
notions about the show seeing what like
it did to like kim and kyle's
relationship and how
it might be toxic so she doesn't need
the money she doesn't need the fame but
it might be like a fun project for her
to work on i think she's
probably glad about being cast as a
housewife or it was even her idea
just to see if it's even remotely
something she would be interested in
yeah
i just don't know why it would be like
i don't know why she would do this i
don't know what she stands to gain from
it
like i feel like if she wanted to be
famous like there were so many
opportunities in her life where she
could have been that's clearly like not
what she wanted
and i don't i mean i don't know her
maybe we'll see a different side to her
but the woman that like
i think that she is i just like i feel
like she's
i feel like honestly if you don't need
the money i think it's like a fun and
easy
job where it like maybe it's for women
who like i haven't always worked
and are looking for like their thing in
like their marriage or just like in
their life like to have something that
they can
call theirs and it's like a fun job
where you get to travel and like wear
makeup and like beautiful clothes and be
friends with fabulous ladies like
for someone who doesn't need the money
and who's not like desperate to get on
like i don't see a downside
unless they paint the outside like there
you never know what is going to happen
how
you know the personalities are going to
mesh and what
the country's going to think of you
that's true i think it's it's a risk but
a lot of people take that risk
because the payoffs of your business
will this and your platform will that
and
if you're someone who doesn't need those
things why even take that risk to begin
with
yeah being a friend isn't a huge risk no
it's not
i mean maybe she sees kyle who was in a
similar situation as her like very
fancy and and thriving thriving and kyle
loves the show and it's brought her so
much good in her life and so maybe she's
just like
i want that good time yeah of course and
i just feel like at some point like when
you're so rich like you get bored
when you're so rich and you don't work
yeah
something to think about something to
think about but it's exciting i'm here
for the casting we're getting closer to
like the kris jenner
yeah i think it's a good direction like
for the show
to be moving in and i'm here
i'm here for what it means me too for
the message fifth and final story is for
claudia
mcclarty ashrae keith renierer reader
of nexium has been sentenced to 120
years in prison
that is so crazy it's so wonderful you
know um
for all of us who made it through the
endless hours of the vow
even though it was tedious at times he
really was just like an
awful evil person and i think this is
just
wonderful news and and i don't think we
i think that was the best it ever went
you know the best it could have went yes
the arrogant 60 year old sicko
according to the new york post oh my
that's [ __ ] savage who billed himself
as gandhi for the wayward only to be
unmasked as a perverted master
manipulator remained defiant until the
end insisting to the judge that his slew
of accusers were lying
but brooklyn federal judge nicholas
garafouis
scoffed at the notion calling this
bengali's crimes cruel perverse and
extremely serious
as he ensured the khan would remain in
prison for life
to him the brave victims are liars the
judge
said bringing down the on the sex
trafficker including
him to pay a 1.75 million dollar fine
well you know this
is truly the justicism system at its
best
and i think you know the wheels of
justice just did what they were supposed
to do and i'm i'm just
thrilled about the idea that like this
guy who went from like being in charge
of thousands of people and manipulating
them all and using them as pawns for his
own
personal sexual financial gain is now
going to be like the bottom of the totem
pole in a men's prison
and i'm just like i think that that
juxtaposition
is poetic and beautiful yeah we love to
see justice being served and justice was
most definitely certain
most definitely um i think a few people
in this
thing are still awaiting sentencing
allison mack yeah i haven't seen a
sentencing for her
and the bronfman girls who to me
are just as bad if not worse than keith
or neary
when i watch him on the documentary
their involvement made me so mad i don't
know why
like well obviously because what they
did is terrible and like they financed
this whole thing but like
can you imagine being born into wealth
like that like literally you turn 18 you
inherit 125 million dollars and
literally you didn't even fart like you
didn't [ __ ] do anything for that
money
and this is what you do like you join a
cult in albany and you ruin people's
lives and like
like that's i understand like
not that i understand but i could see
how someone could become you know drunk
off their own power and like start a
cult like
i don't relate to it but i could see how
it happens i don't see how like you're
literally born
so privileged into such a like such a
legacy and this is what you do with it
like
their involvement for some reason like
really made me angry
damn because they finance the whole
thing and they used all their powerful
connections they got the dalai lama
to come all the way to albany and have
this discussion and
really legitimize this self-help
organization the dalai lama thinks it's
okay
oh of course and their influence and
their power was just as
destructive as keith ranieri's it really
was so
the nexium chapter like is closing and
like it's the luxurious chapter in the
book and i'm like happy for them
um but this is great this is great news
and the vow season two
is happening and i i heard that it's
about like the aftermath which like the
quartz yeah like it's aftermathing
currently i might not watch it but i did
hear that the stars documentary on
nexium is
very good are you going to watch it now
that you're like really a nexum expert
no i am
and i never intended obviously the next
documentary that they make after
the stars one you're going to be honest
i'm the documentary expert
the illusory the miseries cult of all
time and that's where i feel like
the hbo documentary like missed you know
like he was really trying to become
like an influential thing and when your
most famous person is alison mack like
you're not influencing anyone
is that it um okay let's talk about the
bachelor yes
tv recap brought to you by honey
literally the most fabulous brand ever
these days it feels like online shopping
is the only shopping we really do
that's where today's sponsor honey comes
in it's the free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes
and automatically applies the best
available ones at checkout honey is
basically your online shopping best
friend
here's how it works you get honey on
your computer for free and two easy
clicks by going to joinhoney.com
toast then when you're checking out on
one of its over 30 000 supported
sites so i use it at bloomingdale's
revolve ulta sephora literally any
at most popular retailers are a part of
honey
so when you're shopping there honey pops
up and all you have to do is click apply
coupons they scour the internet wait a
few seconds
as they search for the coupons and if
honey finds a working coupon code it'll
apply the best
um most savings one to your cart it's
literally free to download saves you
money i don't know why anyone would not
use it and if you don't know about it i
found out about it from the toasters
they were the one who told me about it
it has saved me so much money um they
have found it's over 17 million members
over two billion dollars in savings
and they support all kinds of retailers
from tech to gaming websites to fashion
brands food delivery
makeup like anything that you use online
shopping for
most likely uses honey it's simple
if you have a computer honey should be
on it it's free and works with whatever
browser you use
you can get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com
toast to get the browser extension for
free download it and start shopping and
saving money today
sign on save money with honey okay
so with the bachelor rhett recap i think
let's go in order of
how things happened because first it
popped off with yo safe
the rose ceremony got cut short the
cocktail party she just went straight to
the road ceremony
because and and the thing with yosef is
going into his discussion and even last
week
i knew he was a dick but i didn't
disagree with his grievances
right of course like he had two points
the first one was
naked no that was the second one the
first one was the way that she like
flipped out on everyone on their first
because literally there was an awkward
silence and that's like really what you
had said
rubbed him the wrong way and honestly
watching it was uncomfortable i was like
that's weird
and then the second one was suspicious
it was naked dodgeball which was not
appropriate now so his two points we
agree with the points
and you know his point about being a
father and like having a family
and if that was him on that date like he
would have been put in a really
uncomfortable situation like i actually
kind of respected that sure like so he
went from having two
very valid valid points to just [ __ ]
being a disgrace and you know at first i
was like
wow he's kind of being
he was mansplaining a little bit but he
wasn't being
disrespectful and then he just
lost it animal like you're not fit to be
the mother of my kids like go [ __ ]
yourself
literally so disgusting following she's
trying to run away from him in this
conversation and he's following her like
his behavior was
disgusting and he just had what he had
like
the moral like he had the argument on
his side
and he just [ __ ] destroyed it and now
he's like a joke and i don't know if
he'll ever be able to get a date again
because the way he spoke to her was
absolutely disgraceful
the names that he called her the way he
followed her around just unbelievably
disgusting it was so shame on him
and he just like went in so hard on her
and like and it's
crazy because he opened up the
conversation like looking like he might
want to be having a productive
conversation let her know how he was
feeling so that like
he could stay in this situation like
feel better about being here you know
like have a
conversation but then like the more he
talked like the more it was clear like
wait so are you telling us you're
leaving like and you're just like make
taking a [ __ ] on your way out
or like do you really think that you're
being like helpful like you're being
someone's like boyfriend like no
you're insane insane he had to go
but i just wanted it to be on the record
and i'm not like such a
i'm not so like a claire hater but he
did have
valid points and i don't think any of
the guys picked up on what he was
picking up on until a little later in
the episode
and none of them would have spoken to
her that way and actually loved how like
protective they are of her and they all
like ran to go get her
except like dale ran to go get her and
she was like and dale was the one who
came up to me i'm like actually the four
guys who were actually on your date ran
up to you first but like i guess you
didn't see them
yeah no [ __ ] what were you the other
guys eventually like are coming around
to what he
saw but the no one would ever have said
it in the way that he said it to say
that she's not fit to be the mother of
his children
literally and you're the oldest
bachelorette in history for a reason
like go [ __ ] yourself like what you're
what you're so great
that was really disturbing yeah i could
see like why she was disturbed why there
was going to be no more conversation
like that is the sort of thing that just
like
shakes you yeah and dale was there for
her and it was just another layer to
their existing connection of like she
felt safe and protected by him so like
of course you know this is moving their
relationship
very far ahead progressing than the
others
yeah and so i of course understood why
she was shaken up
and needed to take time off but again
it's like all these guys literally have
never even spoken to her like
she just keeps and this time it wasn't
her fault and i don't blame her at all
but like
she just keeps cutting down the time
that she gets to see what these guys
spend with these guys
and she knows who's gonna win in her
head and i feel like you know there are
many seasons of the bachelor were like
you know you know ben higgins said he
knew was lauren like
you know but you play the game and she's
just not playing the game and she's not
giving
any of the guys another chance because
then the next day for the day date
she didn't show up and then she just did
the nighttime cocktail party
well yeah so i wasn't upset i didn't
realize it was a pattern of her cutting
time short until
that date where she said can we just
rush through this
yeah and she came they were all dressed
for the day they sat around for like
three hours then she came and told them
it was only gonna be a night date
and she just wanted to rush through that
and spend all of her time with dale then
i was like okay we have
a problem here right and that's where
it's like you're really just kind of
slapping the guys in the face who
quarantined for two weeks at home flew
across the country quarantined for
another two weeks
just to be yes to be on tv but
ultimately to be your boyfriend
and it's really disrespectful then it
got even crazier when she had her second
date that dale was not on
she found a way for dale to be on the
date and then spend the part that he
wasn't there talking about him right and
then got upset with the guys for not
having productive conversations with her
when all she was interested in talking
about was dead
you're jumping ahead you're jumping out
no but i'm saying like that waste of
time like was
constantly compounded in the episode
like just when i thought it couldn't get
worse like
that she's gonna at least pretend like
she's interested in someone else
it was got worse right so then right so
the group date she cut everyone's time
off and then spent the whole time with
dale
dale made that weird ass speech and
wanted to do a group hug
honestly like i'm not mad at dale cause
like they're having a connection and
like that's what love is but like
don't be such a freak in the words of
easy own it yeah no easy is definitely
like a
like a voice of reason in the group 100
and it's true like dale being a freak
and being like i'm only going to take
five minutes let's do a group hug and
then proceeding to take an hour and then
like
walk in on her when she's with someone
else and honestly yes it's on dale
because he was being a freak
she should have never said come sit down
that was not cool like claire they're
acting like
two-year-olds like yes i get that you're
in love there are rules like there's a
process
and the producers are doing her [ __ ]
dirty because
the way that the show is edited it's
always to protect the lead you want the
lead
that's like when everyone was confused
by a lot of what was going on in nick
viall's season
um so many so much was edited and cut
out that it made no sense and it was
like drama between vanessa and rachel
and none of that was ever showed because
vanessa got the final rose and you want
to protect
her and nick like that's what but
because claire is obviously not like the
permanent lead they're doing her [ __ ]
dirty like with all the hidden cameras
and the mics like can we just rush
through this and it's like she's like i
don't even see the point i'm like
seeing these other guys yeah but i think
that even though
a lot of leads do know immediately
there's a reason why you're on the
bachelor you know maybe your first
instinct of who's the best choice for
you isn't the best choice for you so you
give all these other very eligible guys
a shot so that at the end you can even
if it turns out to be that guy
you are 100 sure because you saw
everything else that was out there and
you're like no
i still want this person like even
though the bachelor is like
the most like backwards show like
whatever there's a method
to why oh sometimes it really does work
and why in those few weeks
you are so certain of the person that
you choose and before we saw this week's
episode i really did think that
claire and dale were just like meant for
each other and unfortunately they met in
this circumstance and so they had to
ruin the show
but now i'm feeling like i don't know if
they're gonna make it i think it's like
a physical attraction
puppy love sort of thing she's not even
being mature enough with her feelings to
like recognize that
you know maybe i should give someone
else a shot maybe what i always
initially go for isn't what's best for
me
and i feel like i'm worried for them
because the way because they're gonna
blow up the show and then maybe not even
work out the way that they're acting
is not mature no it's really it's you're
right no
like there's to me i don't know
what besides the physical connection
they have in common or
what she knows about him that she loves
like yeah when he walked over and gave
you a hug like
there's more to a relationship than
feeling safe and a lot of times on the
bachelor like you have a strong initial
connection with someone
but that's not always the person that
you choose like even ben higgins gave
the first impression rose told him
and like for a few weeks i think he was
really like so interested in olivia and
i think
usually you have a few people that
you're like really kind of interested in
and then by the end you know exactly who
it is but you have to
go through the process in order to be
sure of that decision at the end like
cutting it off two weeks in
i just you're it's very it's extremely
hasty it's extremely hasty it's not a
recipe for success
and i wish them the best of luck and i
pray that that it is
so during that group date where she was
just like running off with dale like
acting like a two-year-old and i think
she was very drunk because towards the
end she was slurring her words she
really started to rub me the wrong way
they both did
and all the other guys were starting to
pick up on it and then the next day she
had her one or
her one-on-one with zack c i believe his
name is
who um i don't know if anyone noticed he
owns a clean uh a housekeeping service
and literally
if i was on the bachelorette like i
would choose him 100 like to marry
someone who
owns a cleaning company like oh my god
hell of a like free housekeeping
praise the lord jesus name we say amen
um and he's such a cutie and he's like
kind of shy and like honestly
i think if it weren't like this insane
season he would have had like long-term
potential he's so cute
i mean he got the second one on one
which is usually someone who has
long-term potential
and my god the date was just a disgrace
yes they might not have had a lot of
chemistry but like claire
was not even trying and he was like
visibly nervous and she was like putting
avocados on his face just so he would
like shut the [ __ ] up
and it was just awful and the date was
pathetic because they're stuck in this
hotel and they're getting like
pedicures on like portable pedicure
baths like not even like a real
pedicure chairs and then they're
swimming in her backyard on like a fun
boy float and it was just absolutely
pathetic and of course the whole thing
came to a head
when she went in for a kiss and then
like decided she didn't want to kiss him
the vibe that i got was that she felt
like she was cheating on dale and she
was like going in because she thought
she was supposed to do and then right
when she was about to kiss him she was
like wait no no i'm in love with dale
like i'm not gonna cheat on my boyfriend
and did she ever give us a reason for
why the kiss stopped like
she said that she felt him pull away and
so she got like embarrassed
okay which i did not see zach c
swears that he didn't pull away i i
rewatched it he didn't pull away but he
he was just standing there like ready
for the kiss like he
he didn't do much leaning in so by the
way so that was awkward but what
proceeded to happen afterwards was like
her like running away and like him going
towards her and like her getting like
scared of him
and thinking that like he was grabbing
her and it triggered her
really deeply because then we see in the
little hidden cameras that like she
kind of felt like a breakdown she
started crying and she didn't show up to
the date
and for me it was like i felt two ways
because one
it really i didn't think it was that big
of a deal and
and i thought even if she didn't like
him to not even show up to the date was
like really rude and like have chris
harrison send him home but then part of
me was like
she's deeply triggered by this and i
actually think
what we don't know about there's
probably a lot we don't know about
claire and i think she actually might be
like a very damaged person because
i think that she's been through a lot
that we don't know about and that
what to us seemed like like it was
awkward but it wasn't like
to her it was deeply triggering yeah and
i think that she is like
she has like demons and i think that she
maybe hasn't fully worked them out yet
and it really it made me feel sad first
like part of me was like that's rude
like go say bye to him if you even if
you don't like him and then part of me
was like
really feeling bad she couldn't even
look at him again right so part of me
was like
actually feeling really bad for her like
yeah there's way more here
yeah i felt bad for her because by when
that second
in interaction happened when he was like
no wait give me a kiss
yeah and like he put his hand on her
neck to like bring her in
but at that point like she didn't want
to kiss him so to have someone that you
don't want to kiss like
try and like bring you by the neck no
thank you
yeah but i don't think zack c is like a
bad no or uh aggressive guy i just think
it was so awkward he was doing anything
he could to make it better and
also like he was on a one-on-one date
and she didn't want to like i don't know
what happened at that kiss where it was
a non-start
but like she didn't want to be kissing
him no she was doing it because like so
like part of being the bachelorette is
like kissing people that you don't want
to kiss like you just gotta you kiss all
the guys yeah
and being on a one-on-one like you're
gonna kiss yeah and
so it just got so weird and then got
worse
and i honestly i really felt badly for
both of them i feel i felt like zack c
was put in
like in a bad situation where he was
embarrassed and like chris had to walk
him out not even claire and
it was like just an embarrassing way to
go out and then i also felt bad for
claire because she's obviously
and maybe we don't understand it but
she's going through something like in
that she was going through something
in that moment no i think a lot of
people can understand that and i don't
think
people after like the whole exchange
happened i don't think people are like
faulting claire in any way
it was just like a a a very bad a very
awkward
things lose and then to watch it was
painful
was really painful everyone was a loser
there like it was just
it was awful yeah but it was
it was honestly and we watch a lot of
reality tv like
one of the top five like most shocking
scenes i've ever seen
awkward uncomfortable i didn't like i
literally
i gasped like when when chris showed up
like we know when they cut
when they cut from the pool scene to
write to him being alone at dinner and
like you knew where i was going like i
wanted to cry like my heart really broke
for him and for her no i was glad that
that chris showed up in not claire
because i'm glad that they didn't have
to have a conversation about what
happened like
just everyone let's see well they're
gonna they're going to have to address
it at the men tell all because
there was so many unanswered questions
what was like my jaw
the floor was the first kiss where it
just like they were it was so
like weird i don't know what happened me
neither
it was i just like i feel so sad for
everyone like if i if we talk about it
any longer like i actually might cry
because it was really really sad like
the whole thing
i agree then the next group date was the
roast
where margaret's show was by the way
margaret cho looked great she was very
funny
um of course she brought in all the
other guys just so she could see dale
and she was like shook
it's like she's been living in this
fantasy world like she has no idea
what's going on
and the fact that like literally all the
guys [ __ ] hate dale and that really
came through at the roast
um my favorite from the roast was
bennett he was a little mean but like i
just like
i love him and i said from day one like
if i was on the bachelorette like i'm
going with the guy
who has the rolls-royce yeah also like
someone roasted him by calling him
wealthy
yeah and then i was wondering like if
claire was like you know but then he
went and it was like
no yeah no um the rose wasn't even like
in my opinion remotely interesting
except for the fact that like clearly
everyone hates dale yeah
but here's what was interesting to me
ben major cutie
he who the [ __ ] is ben okay um he was
the one he said
does he look like blake but he's like a
little taller no
no he said he he did a joke about dale
that was funny and landed he said that
he had 43 jokes that he did and so he
did one about
one about claire at the end that was the
only one that aired the one about dale
and it was the only one that she asked
him about he did 43 jokes and she only
cared about that he was so cute he was
so cute and so funny and in any other
season like he's a top three
he's top four he's hometown i agree he's
so cute and like
nerdy a little bit she's great guys i
don't know any of them i don't know what
they do who they are what their names
are where they're from how old they are
there were a few faces where and i never
am this person because i actually feel
like
i hate when people are like who's this
person right no but like
literally there were three people where
i was like have you been here the whole
time no there's no way and when claire
when they did the bloopers
and not bloopers at the end after the
credits when claire like said to one of
the guys i thought i sent you home last
week
that was so i don't watch them it was
like one of the most random it was a fox
i swear i've never seen that that is
so funny yeah um okay but so back to
that date like claire literally is
pulling everyone over and she thinks
she's being subtle she doesn't realize
that all the guys are like
talking about what they spoke about with
claire because she's like
so like what was all these jokes about
dale like
what was that about and then like she
thought she was being so subtle when
literally all the guys knew exactly what
she was doing she was like
yeah but then she wouldn't let it go
every guy was like honestly like i
haven't gotten that much time with you
like could we literally talk about
something else and she's like
no but like what was that about yeah and
you know what i
unders like she wasn't even going about
it in the right way because if it were
me or someone else they would be like oh
my god the whole house hates
my man like that's something that has
come up before where it's like am i
dating the villain
right and you the conversation that you
would have is like
is there something i don't know like
more out of real concern
not like why would you go after my man
when she walked away and said they're
talking [ __ ] about my fiance
i was like that was that's no wonder why
they didn't keep going they could they
could sense from her that like
oh saying more negative stuff about dale
would only get them sent home
yeah they would not be like giving her
information that she needed she just
like
that scene was crazy like that's what
crazy girls do like i did that like
within a day of meeting bed i'm like
that's my boyfriend like
but you weren't dating 25 other guys who
you were on national television no i
didn't pretend
it's just like that's what crazy girls
do like when you call someone your
boyfriend and they're like not your
boyfriend she didn't even call her
she said beyonce that was crazy that was
crazy
and what was even crazier was she again
couldn't even pretend play the game
didn't give a rose oh that was see
that's
she really lost me there in that
instance she should have just given the
rose to the person who was the funniest
at the rose whoever got the most last
i'm sure there was a consensus
yeah who was the funniest you should
have been like you really impressed me
today like you were out of your comfort
zone like she can't
i love a funny guy like thank you for
putting yourself out
she can't even act and half of this show
is just acting
yeah yeah so that's where and it because
in the promo for next week we see tasha
like
it obviously she can't go on we're only
three episodes in and she's not even
playing the game
and the guys are very aware of what's
happening this is a season unlike any
other there's
they're not in these like fabulous
cities with all these distractions and
all these dates like they're literally
in on top of each other like on a date
and there's less distraction so like
it's extremely clear what's going on i'm
glad that the guys are like going to
stand up for themselves
because it's a waste of their time and
it's embarrassing and like
i i it's just unproductive for them i
completely agree and i'm really looking
forward to teaching oh my god
that sickening scene of her getting out
of the pool was truly just like movie
magic
and i love how excited everyone is like
i feel like we can rally behind someone
and you know in these divided times it's
like
tasha is our leader and we're all just
like rallying behind her
and i'm very excited for her to take
over i really am i think she'll
she'll respect the process and what's so
funny about this whole thing is that
tweet of claire's that's going
completely viral like what is it
well when matt james was cast for her
season and there were like rumors that
he was like on cameo and like starting
like being thirsty
people were tweeting about it and she
like had him removed from her cast and
tweeted something like
respect the opportunity you've been
given respect the process respect the
position
and it's like claire claire
respect the opportunity you've been
given like at least
pretend yeah and they would have cut if
she had even done a decent job at
pretending
they would have cut out obviously all
the things where she's referring to him
as her fiance
the lead doesn't get hot miked that's
not what happens like it's for the other
contestants like the lead is protected
when it comes to editing
but between how they edited her
conversations post roast
to all of her like behind the scenes hot
mic moments like they're doing her
[ __ ] dirty
yeah but they also need to like make us
understand explain to the viewers how we
got to this place you know it's
different there's a difference between
having a front runner
and considering yourself engaged when
you're still dating 20 guys
yeah um no it's just really bizarre and
i'm really looking forward
it was an amazing episode like it was
and i and i've been very hesitant
um about this season but it's pretty
good
yeah yeah it is we're having interesting
conversations like it's not silliness
and it's like a trope a storyline that
we really have never seen before and i
love
when things are have never been done
before yeah so that's our bachelorette
recap
no other tv was on right no but we have
dear toasters it's in your email we
forgot to print it today but oh my god i
totally forgot
your emails so our dear toasters advice
segment is coming right up
okay ready to give out some advice i am
i am i
am just take a moment it's refreshing
just give me one second
[Music]
dude
[Music]
hey queens by the way dear toasters is
our advice segment if you're ever
looking to write in our email is dear
toasters gmail.com
hi queens love listening to you guys
every morning it's honestly been great
for my sanity during all of this coveted
[ __ ] and it adds some much needed
routine to my day
i'm in an awkward situation with my
stepsister
she's decided to uninvite my boyfriend
to her wedding our entire family will be
there and would definitely raise red
flags and suspicion if he wasn't there
she absolutely hates him and here's why
earlier this year i made the mistake in
opening
up to her about issues in in our
relationship i don't want to go into
detail but he cheated on me
i'd been dealing with this privately for
a little bit more than a year and i was
so tired of keeping it in
so i confided in my sister for support
and love
and all that stuff she really does not
support me staying with him and trying
to figure
things out for the sake of our
relationship and family because we have
a two-year-old son together
my question is do you think it's fair
for her to uninvite him to her wedding i
understand that this is her day and
she's been looking forward to this day
forever
and that you wouldn't want to pay for a
plate for someone you hate but i
honestly would consider
not going if i can't bring my boyfriend
he's basically my husband minus the
legality plus our son is the ring bearer
and i don't want him to miss our son
walking down the aisle
but i'm so i'm also in the wedding party
and as well so i really can't skip out
also he was already invited now he's
uninvited help what do i do
yeah no that's that ain't right of your
sister first of all like wedding party
gets a plus one
yeah and also it's your wedding party
plus ones if your sister slash
bridesmaid
has a boyfriend who she has a child with
who they're together like
he gets invited right but even if like
you it wasn't even that serious but it
is like you're the sister you got a plus
one
no and also it's not like this boyfriend
did anything to your
sister like he did something to you
you're choosing to be with him and like
that's on you
and it really should have nothing to do
with your sister yeah i think that
ultimately like you should definitely go
to the wedding but i would say give it
one more shot
where you ask your sister if he can come
like
and explain to her like where you're at
now it's so hard when people like
you know you you want to share with
people like what's going on in your life
but then like people hold grudges and
it's like that's not your grudge to hold
yeah that's hard and you shouldn't feel
honestly
people who you open up to who then like
hold that information against you like
that kind of
that's really shitty yeah and i
understand like she loves you and she
wants to protect you
but she also needs to support you and
this and the ultimate decision that
you've made like you've made your
decision
yeah so you need to be supported and so
that's a bummer i would say try and keep
like
talking to her about it and i mean it is
her wedding so like don't stress her out
if it doesn't work out just use it as
something to hold over her head like for
the rest of your life
yeah but i do think you regardless of
what happens like you have to go to the
wedding yeah and you're
your son's the ring bearer like yeah
that's so cute try and work it out with
your
sister directly but i wouldn't knock out
because that's something that's like a
life moment you can't you'll regret that
yeah
all right next up hi girls i'm pregnant
with my first child due mid-march
congrats with a sweet baby toaster
i am planning my baby shower and want to
have it in the final weeks of january so
i can have time to set up
prepare buy anything else that i need i
live in the midwest my mom and sister
live in the southwest
my grandparents go there every winter
from january to march every year to get
out of the snow
anyways i've been planning for this baby
shower since september and told my
mother my plans at the time
i just found out today that she doesn't
plan to come to my baby shower and my
sister and grandma won't come either
unless i change the date
closer to march i think that's pretty
unreasonable of an ask especially
considering the unpredictability of
birth
i don't personally think it's too much
to ask them to be here for a weekend or
my grandparents to go a little later to
be here
maybe i'm being in reasonable but this
puts me in a really hard spot
what's their reasoning for not warning
that they usually yeah the weather they
fly
uh south for the cold months so it's
like
have it in march because we're gonna be
out from january to march
um maybe i'm being unreasonable but this
puts me in a really hard spot
i'm extremely introverted and i don't
have a ton of friends so it's a lot for
my family not to be there for me
for further context my younger sister
has also wanted me to reschedule my
bridal shower
for her convenience and that caused a
huge fight around my wedding please
help that's tough
normally if it were like a normal world
i would say you know
like everyone should be able to come
stand your ground
but people are very trepidatious about
flying right now
to fly in like a bad weather situation
where it
not work out with flights or like
there's a snowstorm and and you have
your mom and your grandma and there's
like covet and it's just like
that's a lot to ask of people i think
it's a lot to ask people to even fly
right now like
um and so i feel like you should try and
make something in february work i
understand not wanting to be like so
close to your due date
but i think if you can push it back i
think
that you should it's still so it's still
only october like like i feel like it's
okay to push it back right now you know
i mean at the end of the day like this
is your family and i do think that
they're being slightly unreasonable
but you want them there so if the the
only way to get them there is for you to
accommodate for them then
i think that's what you have to do
because it doesn't sound like they're
going to
do the same for you yeah but family's
family maybe they won't get the exact
date that they want to be there maybe if
they could come like two weeks before
that
but i i'm sure it's like so annoying i
just feel like
there's only so much you can ask of
people right now and like to compound
like
bad weather with kobit and travel and
all of that like it's
it's a lot for people to do um so just
keep that in mind but that sucks i'm
sorry yeah it sucks when there's like
family drama
she was being very vague about northwest
southwest i don't know where exactly
we'll go oh yeah i love a baby shower
just as long as you have good snacks
all right final one hey claude and
jackie you're both beautiful stunning
and smart and i look forward to the
toast every day
thank you i met my boyfriend on bumble
right at the start of 2020.
we were not exclusively dating up until
quarantine and things cooled down for a
bit
then three months
ago we started exclusively dating again
quite seriously my boyfriend told me
in the beginning that he is casually
hooked up with guys in the past
and i have no issue with that but
something feels strange with his best
friend
on new year's eve of this year just
before we met my guy and his best friend
got drunk and celebrated together
my boyfriend told me how when they were
drunk they started making out and almost
progressed to more in his bed but
stopped themselves
and then things were kind of weird
between them for a few weeks i've tried
bringing back up this story to get more
clarity and my boyfriend shuts it down
immediately
it's not a big deal to me but it does
feel strange i also feel like my
boyfriend is less touchy and attentive
around me when his best friend is around
i think i'm reading too much into this
but they've been best friends since they
were kids would love to hear your
thoughts slash any advice love you guys
and thanks
so much this is tough this is tough and
this is i feel like a situation where
it's much easier
to um give advice than it is to follow
through
but like i feel like part of being in a
relationship
is being completely open when it comes
to sexuality and like your past
and i think that you have to like not be
afraid to ask questions and if you are
feeling weird like i would listen to
your gut like
if your boyfriend is acting different
when he's around his best friend like
there might be something going on like
listen to your gut don't you're not
maybe you're not being crazy
and it's hard to be with someone who's
had like a romantic relationship with
their best friend and that best friend
is still their best friend and like
and this wasn't so um far in the past
right it was
still this year so if there's stuff
lingering there and you
like not only do you know that this
happened but you're
feeling like it's there as well i i
would say trust your gut um don't come
at it from not from like a judgmental
place just like a genuine place of
concern
yeah like it just feels like your
boyfriend has feelings for someone else
while you're with him yeah and just feel
like i don't just say like i don't like
being in the dark i'm getting a weird
vibe i know that i'm not crazy like what
the hell is going on
yeah maybe not like what the hell just
be like but
be like this is how i feel is there
something you want to tell me is there
something you want to tell me or is
there any merit to like the way that i'm
feeling
or am i reading the room wrong yeah but
i would
i wouldn't like invalidate your own
feelings like gut instinct and like gut
reaction like there's real value in that
and like
listen to your heart yeah listen to your
heart and that gut
it knows something um so that was dear
toasters i hope we gave some good advice
to your toasters gmail.com is the email
account if you want to write in it is
always anonymous
and it is always you know fabulous
advice totally
that's our show thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heard a cat box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing hump day we
will see you tomorrow for thursday's
episode
and huzzah goodbye
you